Les entreprises génèrent ces ressources
quand elles réalisent un bénéfice.
Ce bénéfice représente la différence
entre le prix et le coût de production
quelle que soit la solution que l'entreprise a créée,
pour tenter de résoudre un problème.
Mais ce bénéfice est la magie ici.
Pourquoi ? Parce que ce bénéfice
permet de faire de la solution que l'on a créée
quelque chose d'infiniment transposable.
Parce que si on peut faire un bénéfice,
on peut le faire pour 10, 100, un million,
100 millions, un milliard.
La solution se suffit à elle-même.
C'est ce qu'une entreprise réalise
quand elle génère un bénéfice.
Alors, quelle est la relation
avec les problèmes sociaux ?
Eh bien, une façon de voir les choses consiste à dire :
prenons ce bénéfice et redéployons-le vers les problèmes sociaux.
Les entreprises devraient donner plus.
Les entreprises devraient être plus responsables.
Cela a toujours été notre vision
dans les entreprises.
Mais encore une fois, cette façon de voir les choses
n'est pas en train de nous mener là où nous devrions aller.
J'ai commencé comme professeur de stratégie,
et je suis toujours professeur de stratégie.
Je suis fier de cela.
Mais au fil des ans, j'ai travaillé
de plus en plus souvent sur des projets à caractère social.
J'ai travaillé sur la santé, l'environnement,
le développement économique, la réduction de la pauvreté,
et à mesure que je travaille de plus en plus dans le domaine social,
j'ai commencé à percevoir quelque chose
qui a eu un impact profond sur moi
et sur toute ma vie, en quelque sorte.
L'idée la plus répandue en économie
dans la vision de l'entreprise a toujours été
qu'il existe un compromis
entre la performance sociale et la performance économique.
L'idée la plus répandue consistait à dire
que l'entreprise réalise un bénéfice
en induisant de fait un problème social.
L'exemple classique est la pollution.
Si l'entreprise pollue, elle fait plus d'argent
que si elle tentait de réduire cette pollution.
Réduire la pollution coûte cher,
donc les entreprises ne veulent pas le faire.
Il est rentable d'avoir un environnement de travail dangereux.
Cela coûte trop cher d'avoir un environnement de travail sûr.
Donc les entreprises gagnent plus d'argent
si elles n'ont pas un environnement de travail sûr.
C'est l'idée la plus répandue.
Beaucoup d'entreprises ont succombé à cette idée.
Elles ont résisté aux mesures écologiques,
à l'amélioration des conditions de travail.
Je crois que cette réflexion a conduit
à forger une grande partie du comportement
que nous critiquons chez les entreprises,
et que je critique moi-même.
Mais en fait, plus je m'investissais dans tous ces problèmes sociaux,
l'un après l'autre,
et plus je tentais d'y remédier
moi-même, personnellement, dans certains cas,
à travers des organismes à but non lucratif dans lesquels je me suis impliqué,
plus je trouvais effectivement que la réalité
se trouvait à l’opposé.
L'entreprise ne gagne rien
à induire des problèmes sociaux,
pas dans un sens fondamental.
C'est une vision très simpliste.
Plus on se penche sur ces questions,
plus on commence à comprendre
qu'en fait les entreprises gagnent
à résoudre les problèmes sociaux.
C'est de là que provient le véritable bénéfice.
Prenons l’exemple de la pollution.
Nous avons appris récemment que le fait
de réduire la pollution et les émissions
générait des bénéfices.
Cela fait économiser de l'argent.
Cela rend l'entreprise plus productive et efficace.
Cela évite de gaspiller les ressources.
Avoir des conditions de travail plus sûres
et éviter les accidents
rendent l'entreprise plus rentable,
parce que c'est la preuve de bons procédés.
Les accidents sont onéreux et coûteux.
Problème après problème, on commence à apprendre
qu'en réalité il n'y a pas de compromis
entre le progrès social
et l'efficacité économique
dans un sens fondamental.
Un autre problème est la santé.
J'entends par là que l'on a découvert que
la santé des employés est quelque chose
que les entreprises devraient soigner,
parce qu'un bon état de santé permet aux employés
d'être plus productifs
et moins souvent absents.
La recherche poussée, la récente recherche, la nouvelle pensée
sur l'interface entre les entreprises et les problèmes sociaux
montrent qu'il existe en réalité une fondamentale
et profonde synergie,
surtout si on ne raisonne pas à très court terme.
A très court terme, on peut parfois
se tromper en pensant
qu'il y a fondamentalement des objectifs opposés,
mais sur le long terme, en fin de compte, on apprend,
que ce n'est tout simplement pas vrai.
Alors, comment peut-on puiser dans
la puissance des entreprises
pour résoudre les problèmes fondamentaux
auxquels nous sommes confrontés ?
Imaginez qu'on puisse faire ça.
Parce que si on le pouvait, on pourrait passer à l'échelle supérieure.
On pourrait puiser dans cette réserve de ressources énormes
et cette capacité organisationnelle.
Et devinez quoi ? C'est ce qui se passe actuellement, enfin.
En partie à cause de gens comme vous
qui ont fait connaître ces problèmes
année après année et décennie après décennie.
On voit des entreprises telles que Dow Chemical
mener une révolution contre les graisses transgéniques
et les graisses saturées grâce à des produits innovants.
Ceci est un exemple de Jain Irrigation.
C'est une entreprise qui a apporté la technologie d'irrigation au goutte à goutte
à des milliers et des millions d'agriculteurs,
réduisant ainsi considérablement la consommation d'eau.
On voit des sociétés comme la société forestière brésilienne Fibria
qui a trouvé un moyen d'éviter
d'abattre les forêts anciennes
en se tournant vers les eucalyptus qui permettent
d'obtenir un meilleur rendement de pâte par hectare
et produire beaucoup plus de papier qu'on ne peut en obtenir
en abattant des arbres centenaires.
On voit des sociétés comme Cisco qui a formé, à ce jour,
quatre millions de personnes en informatique
pour, certes, être responsable,
mais aussi élargir la possibilité
de diffuser l'informatique,
et faire croître l'ensemble de l'entreprise.
Une opportunité fondamentale s’offre aux entreprises d'aujourd'hui
pour agir et s'attaquer à ces problèmes sociaux,
et cette opportunité
est la plus grande opportunité commerciale
qui s'offre aux entreprises.
La question est, comment peut-on transposer cette vision
du monde des affaires au problème de la valeur partagée ?
Voici ce que j'appelle une valeur partagée :
traiter des problèmes sociaux avec un modèle d'entreprise.
Voilà ce qu'est la valeur partagée.
La valeur partagée, c'est le capitalisme,
mais c'est un capitalisme de type supérieur.
Finalement, c'est le capitalisme tel qu'il était censé être :
la satisfaction des besoins importants,
pas la concurrence incessante
dans des différences insignifiantes sur les produits
et les parts de marché.
La valeur partagée, c'est quand on arrive à créer de la valeur sociale
et de la valeur économique simultanément.
Trouver ces opportunités
nous permettra d'atteindre la possibilité ultime
d'apporter une réponse réelle à ces problèmes sociaux
parce que nous pouvons passer à l'échelle supérieure.
Nous pouvons voir la valeur partagée à plusieurs niveaux.
C'est en train de se produire.
Mais pour que cette solution fonctionne,
on doit maintenant changer la façon dont les entreprises se perçoivent,
et cela est heureusement en cours.
Les entreprises se sont retrouvées prises au piège de l'idée répandue.
Elles ont pensé qu'elles ne devaient pas se soucier des problèmes sociaux,
que c'était en quelque sorte quelque chose de secondaire,
que quelqu'un d'autre s'en chargeait.
On voit maintenant des entreprises
adhérer à cette idée.
Mais on doit aussi reconnaître que l'entreprise
ne va pas le faire de manière aussi efficace
qu'elle pourrait le faire en collaborant
avec des ONG et l’État.
Les nouvelles ONG qui sont vraiment arrivées à faire la différence
sont celles qui sont arrivées à conclure ce genre de partenariats
et qui ont trouvé ces façons de collaborer.
Les gouvernements qui font le plus de progrès
sont ceux qui ont trouvé des moyens
d'introduire la valeur partagée dans l'entreprise
plutôt que de laisser le gouvernement
être seul aux commandes.
Et les États ont de nombreuses façons d'avoir une incidence
sur la volonté et la capacité des entreprises
à se lancer dans cette direction.
Je pense que si on pouvait faire en sorte que les entreprises se voient différemment,
et si on pouvait faire en sorte d'amener les autres à voir les entreprises différemment,
nous pourrions changer le monde.
Je le sais. Je le vois.
Je le sens.
Les jeunes, je pense,
comme mes élèves de l'école de commerce de Harvard, l'ont compris.
Si on pouvait briser ce genre de fossé,
ce malaise, cette tension,
ce sentiment que nous ne sommes pas
en train de collaborer fondamentalement
dans la prise en charge de ces problèmes sociaux,
on pourrait casser cette routine,
et je pense, qu'à ce moment-là
on pourra avoir des solutions.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)